πρώτη φορά έχουμε σκεώ διπουρκυβέρνηση σε έ ακόμα έγινε γιατί μυχανλι μουν θεωρίσε ότι περνάκρισει
τα αυτό ένασ τι μο κατικός σώρο σήμερα όχι να σου να πούμε γινα πούμε
γιατί έγινε είναι και νομίζω το έχω ξαναπει καταρχή μουεζητήση για υ ην πρόεδρο να
συμμετέχω σε τον τοσώμα και εγώ δεν είπα ποτέ όχι στων αγοηθήσο ότι δίποτε η
συγκεκριμένη θέση ό ι ένα ανακοινωθεί που ην πρόευρο οι συγκεκριμένες θέσεις κιόδιες ς και
ότης κατοο κκάπινε όπω τολέμε το συμβούλιο παρακολοθείς κυβερνητικού έργουν και είαι ακριβώς αυτό δηλαδή
ποιών εντοκαιπι οιον κιενώ πάει να καλύψει καταρχύ το καινών το χρονικών μια κυβέρνηση όταν
είσ αντιπολίς μια κυβέρνηση ξεκινά μια πολιτική μέσα που τα κυβερνητικά σχήματά της διλαδή μέσα
από τα υπουργία της μέσα χρειάζεσαι έναν πιο πιο κοντ έναν όργανο το οποίο θα
βλέπει ακριβώς αυτά τα θέματα πριν φτάσουν στη βουλή ότα φτάζουν στη βουλήνει ώς να
είναι και αργάαη κάποια ζητήματα κα υπάρχουν παραδείγματα όπως το ιλατικό όπως αλλα θέματα τα
οποία προλάβα με εγκαταστάσεις πολύ πιο νωρίς στο ετατικόν δεν θεώρισε όια κάπω υπερβολικάτα ως
αλέκθηκαν αποπλευρά δημοκρατικύς συναγελμος το έχω εξηγήσει α πιαστεί το το έχω πικι έτσι κιρας
επιαστήκαμε πόυ την τιτλοποίηση της πρότασης ενώαματι και βάσει την πρόταση που έχει κατάτεθεί πυ
ήταν κάτο εθυμέρι ότην ίδιαμερα ήταν ξεκαθαρον ότι ίναι μιλούσαμε και συνταγματική κατάσταση εκτά ακτης
ανάγκης μιλούσαμε για ότιίαι πίγουσαναναγκη γιατιν ανάγκη να πισπευθούν διαδικασίας πράγμα που έγινε στη συνέχεια
αμαδίείται αρκετά πράγματα που γίνονται σήμερα και πιθανόι